[Music]
i'm going to do something that's never
been done before
ever in history and you are going to
witness it
ready
there this is probably the first time
that a deck of cards
has ever been arranged in this specific
order in history
first time think of all the decks of
cards being shuffled around the world
right now think of all the decks of
cards shuffled around the world
throughout history
every gunslinger saloon every poker
night every game i go fish
even taking into account every casino
game ever played
every cheesy magic trick you've ever
seen every time you played solitaire on
your computer
even considering all of that given the
law of probability
the order of the cards in this deck has
probably never
occurred before in the history of the
universe and probably never will again
sounds crazy right let's find out why
welcome to the y files where smart folks
like us get together to talk nerdy and
today we're talking about math facts
that seem to defy logic
your hair defies logic what is that what
is what you look like a one-man boy band
who got old what's on your head
it's hair product hair product
i'm glad i got scales can i just get
through this intro please
go ahead grandpa timberlake do your
thing
glad i got scared math is everywhere
it's the source code of the universe
it's the blueprint for everything
and most of the time math makes perfect
sense right two plus two is four
five times five is twenty-five fine but
sometimes
math just gets weird like the deck of
cards which is bananas by the way
and we'll get to that later in the video
first
we need to ease into it with a couple of
crazy math facts
okay here's one how many people do you
need to get together
before you find two that have the same
birthday here's a hint
not that many in a random group of only
23 people
the chances of two of them sharing the
same birthday is 50
what this is called the birthday paradox
or the birthday problem because it's not
literally a paradox
but it's definitely unintuitive when you
first hear it at least it was for me
so why does this seem so weird well it
turns out we're all a little
self-centered
aren't we a bunch of little snowflakes
so the first thing we want to do is
compare our own birthday against the
other 22 people in the room
that's not how you do it that's only 22
chances to find a match
the chance is not that high instead what
we do is compare all 23
birthdays against each other that gives
us
22 plus 21 plus 20 and so on and so on
ultimately 253 comparisons given that
there are
usually 365 days in a year 253 chances
to find
a birthday match it's 50 now just throw
60 people in the room
chances of finding birthday buddies 99
now there's an actual formula for this
which i cannot explain
but i can link it in the description
below
here's another one that broke my brain
at first let's say you have a rope
wrapped around the earth at the equator
the length of the rope is going to be
about
25 000 miles long right 45 000
kilometers let's say you want that rope
to hover
one foot off the ground 30 centimeters
how much more rope do you need to add to
that whole thing
to make that happen the answer 6.28
feet 1.91 meters that's it that's it
okay
okay that's that that's weird enough
right but here's where the puzzle takes
the express train to crazy town
okay the earth is really big so let's
try the puzzle with something really
small
like a tennis ball how long do rope to
get around the tennis ball
eight inches 20 centimeters so now do
the same thing we want that rope
to hover one foot above the tennis ball
how much more rope do we need to add
same answer 6.28 feet you're sure
i'm sure so what's going on here why
does this seem so
wrong well it's just the way we picture
things in our minds when we talk about
huge objects like the planet our minds
shift into kind of a large number mode
we expect the answer to the puzzle to be
large then when we take the same puzzle
apply it to a small object
our brain shifts into a small number
mode and we want the answer to the
puzzle to be
small but the catch to this math
weirdness is actually kind of obvious
it doesn't matter what size circle we
start with the formula for circumference
is two times pi times the radius whether
our circle of rope is around
an atom or the earth or the entire
universe itself it doesn't matter
when you increase the radius by one foot
the answer is always gonna be the same
it's one foot times two
it's two feet times pi it's three point
one four so we've got two feet times
three point one four
is six point two eight feet every time
when i first saw this
blew my mind okay okay let's take a
break from calculations
i want to show you some really cool math
patterns
[Music]
when i was seven or eight years old my
grandma told me to write down this
sentence
now i don't know why i'm writing but she
was a baddie lady and when she said do
something you did it because something
cool was about to happen
and it totally did i write down the
phrase
and she says it's spelled the same way
backwards
this was the phrase a man a plan a canal
panama it's a palindrome palindrome is a
word or
phrase that's spelled the same way
backwards and forwards and this is a
famous one and there are all kinds of
other famous
palindromes like uh madame in eden i'm
adam
or bob bob is a palindrome but we're
going for something a little more
impressive boob
please poop don't nah i couldn't help
myself all right go on with the thing
the thunderdome
palindrome whatever numbers can be
palindromes too
the number is 44 525 1001
same backwards and forwards you get the
idea here's a cool trick
take the number one square it the answer
is a palindrome now it's a single digit
so it's not that impressive but i'm
going to impress you
i promise now take two number ones
eleven to the common folk
one one times one one equals one hundred
and twenty one
one two one palindrome but it gets
crazier take three
number ones 111 111 times 111 equals
12 321 which is one two three two one
which is a palindrome
but here is how to blow your friends
minds check it out
pick any number from one to nine write
down that many ones
so in our case let's say seven of them
one million one hundred eleven thousand
one hundred eleven
square that huh
watch how fast i get this answer one
trillion two hundred and thirty four
billion 567 million
654 321
that's a palindrome the front half of
our answer will start at one
and count up to the number of digits we
started with in our case seven
and then the back half of the answer
will count down from seven ending at one
side note if you try this with more than
nine digits the palindrome trick breaks
the magic only happens with the numbers
one through nine but there's all kinds
of other palindromes in math
phrases equations formulas all kinds of
cool stuff
we're not talking about those here but
the links are down below
[Music]
look at that we made a history again
here's a hint
it has to do with factorials it's coming
up
nines are mysterious they got a whole
thing going on here's what i want you to
do take a nine
multiply it by a number any number you
want reduce that answer
down to a single digit that digit will
always be
nine every time no matter what what
happens
it it's always nine let me show you how
this works
nine times five is forty-five four plus
five
equals nine easy right now nine
times one hundred and one that's nine
hundred and nine
nine plus zero plus nine equals
eighteen remember we need a single digit
so we keep going one plus eight equals
getting the hang of it all right let's
go bonkers now let's go crazy
nine times the number of days in a year
times the number of bones in the human
body 206
times the number of marvel mcu movies
23. i didn't say good ones not just
total the answer is fifteen million five
hundred sixty four thousand three
hundred thirty
check it out one plus five is six plus
that next five
brings you to eleven plus your next six
gives you 17. add 4
21. add 3 you're at 24 the next three
brings you to 27 add zero
zero it gives you 27. single digit 2
plus 7
equals 9. now if you want to challenge
me on how many days there are in a year
or
bones in the body or number of mcu
movies that's cool
you do you but whatever numbers you plug
in and multiply by nine
your single digit is going to be nine
every time go ahead and try it
nines get crazier now the trick i'm
about to show you when i first saw it
i went blind for three hours and
everything spelled like peanuts
that's i'm just joking you're gonna be
fine but it's a whole rabbit hole
so come just hang in there
take our magical nine square it nine
times nine
is eighty-one now divide that into one
the answer is zero point and then all
the single digits from zero to nine in
order repeating forever
but we always skip your starting number
minus one
in this case eight eight never happens
in the sequence but all the other digits
are there
in order zero point zero one two three
four five six seven skip eight nine and
then it repeats again and again
on and on forever and it gets crazier
let's keep going
let's take two nines ninety-nine square
it the answer is nine thousand
eight hundred and one divide that into
one the answer is zero
point and then every two digit number in
order from zero zero
zero one zero two all the way up to
ninety nine and then repeats forever
again
but again we skip the starting number
minus one
so in this case 99 minus 1 is 98 that
never shows up in the sequence
but all the other numbers do in order
always and forever so does it work if we
keep going
yup let's do 999 squared that's 998
thousand
and one divide into one the answer is
zero point
and now every three digit number in
order from zero zero zero through nine
nine nine
repeating forever and just like before
we skip your starting number minus one
nine nine nine minus one is nine nine
eight
that never shows up in the sequence this
will work with four nines five nines
just on and on
and i was so amazed by this that i
wanted to look up like how it works
okay so here we go there is that all
right cool
all right oh there's actually a
straightforward reason great
okay let's see okay that's not
straightforward to me but if any of that
makes sense to you let me know in the
comments below because i'm taking you to
vegas
or i'm selling you to the circus either
way a great channel called numberphile
did a video on how this works and
there's a whole formula behind it so
the link is well it's where it always is
now when you try this yourself most
calculators or even google won't give
you enough digits to see the pattern
instead they may give you what's called
e-notation which is a type of scientific
notation which is a form of shorthand
but there are some online calculators
that will give you big big numbers and i
will link to my favorite in the
description
exponential progression or exponential
growth is defined as a way that a
quantity
given a common rate of change increases
or decreases over time
let's warm up with a quick puzzle we'll
see how it works i want you to give me
your answer as quickly as you can
no pausing just fire away here goes in a
lake there's a patch of lily pads
now every day the patch doubles in size
if it takes 48 days for the patch to
cover the entire lake
how many days before half the lake is
covered
hecklefish what do you got 24 boom what
do i win
wrong the answer is 47. well think about
it if the size of the patch doubles
every day and fills the lake on day 48
that must mean that half the lake was
covered just the day before
day 47 that just blew my tiny salty mind
when our brains are solving problems
like this we have two modes
intuitive and deliberative fast and slow
at first glance 24 makes sense because
24 is half of 48 it's a really easy math
problem to solve
and our brains love solving problems
quickly we're dopamine junkies and the
faster we get that dopamine the better
but when we slow down
and focus on the premise the answer is
obviously 47
and when we realized we didn't earn that
dopamine our brains punish us with
frustration
now why this happens isn't fully
understood but some experts believe that
our brains are punishing us in order to
condition us to think more slowly and
more logically now we've got a video
coming up on dopamine and other
neurotransmitters
fascinating so please make sure you like
subscribe hit the bell
all the business so how did you do 24 or
be honest if you said 47 right off the
bat
that means your deliberate reasoning is
far above average far above mine
let me know in the comments below how
you did okay exponential growth
what is that well it's defined as how a
quantity increases over time when the
rate of change is proportional to the
quantity
itself in the case of the lily pad
we express that by starting with the
number 1 and just doubling it
1 2 4 8 16 and so on this type of growth
can also be described as geometric
progression with a common ratio
of two meaning you take the last number
in your series
multiply by two get your next number and
keep on trucking
now these numbers can get really big
really quickly
and there's a lot of well-known examples
and parables and histories and stories
and all kinds of
stuff that talks about this with the
chess and the rice
thanks you know how we do but i want to
illustrate exponential growth with
something that made my brain tissue
itchy and it smelled like cheese a
little bit i don't know why
there was oozing but that's that's
typical
it's happening now all right
this is a normal piece of paper it's
about 10 millimeters thick
now if you fold this in half the
thickness is now
20 millimeters let's fold in half again
40 millimeters and so on and so forth
because of the size of the paper the
most number of folds you can get by hand
is like six or seven
unless you're thor and maybe you can get
a few more but sooner or later you're
gonna run out of strength or you run out
of paper
but what if we had a theoretical piece
that was infinitely long and infinitely
wide but still only 10 millimeters thick
how many times would you have to fold it
before it was one kilometer high
just 23 folds at 30 folds that stack of
paper will be 100 kilometers high that
means we're in space people
let's keep folding at 42 folds you reach
the moon
51 folds get you all the way to the sun
how many times would you have to fold
a single sheet of paper that would
create a stack so high that you could
reach the end of the observable universe
which is
93 billion light years away how many
folds you'd only have to fold the paper
103 times
exponential growth can create some
really big numbers but you know what
those numbers are nothing compared to
what we're going to talk about next
factorials and that's where our deck of
cards
comes into play get my agent on the
phone this is a bush league
[Music]
there are a bunch of different formulas
and explanations describing all of these
concepts i will link them below but in
the paper folding example we were
doubling our numbers
or multiplying by a common ratio of two
multiplying by two is doubling right
right but what happens to the numbers in
a sequence when instead of multiplying
by
two we multiply by the next number in
the sequence
that's a factorial in written math a
factorial is represented
as the number followed by an exclamation
point and that's for a good reason
factorials are crazy here's how they
work let's say you want a factorial of
five
you take five multiply by four multiply
by three by two
by one hecklefish what'd you get a
headache the answer is 120.
check it out 5 times 4 times 3 times 2
times 1. 120. so a factorial of 6
is going to be 120 times 6 or in other
words
6 times 5 times 4 times 3 times 2 times
1.
you see where we're going with this the
numbers scale really fast
a small number factorial can be a huge
answer
for example 10 factorial seconds is 6
weeks that's 3 eight
thousand eight hundred seconds and
what's even weirder is it's not five
weeks and change or
six weeks in a bit ten factorial seconds
is six weeks
on the nose how did they do that so what
if factorials have to do with a deck of
cards
well factorials are commonly used in
calculating probabilities
let me show you i took five cards out of
the deck jack of hearts three diamonds
seven of hearts
aces spades ten of clubs now we shuffle
hecklefish
what are the odds that the ace of spades
is the top card
on this deck i'm gonna carry the one
come on buddy you can do it five cards
right
five cards one out of five that's right
one out of five nice job pickle
is back baby but how many different ways
or permutations
can these five cards be rearranged oh no
the answer
is 120 different ways and i'm out
a probability is the chance of a certain
outcome in a specific set so in our case
it's one card out of five but a
permutation
is how many different ways the order of
these cards
can be arranged and rearranged even
though we only have five cards
they could be arranged in 120 different
ways
and if we add just two more cards now
we've got 5
000 different permutations did you just
say 5 000
yep 7 factorial is 5040. all right all
right here's what i need you to do what
i need you to empty out my bowl and
refill it all the way up with vodka
right to the rim
guess daddy needs a break you know
fishbowl martini would make a pretty
good video dawn tootin it would okay so
seven cards is over 5000 permutations
eight cards is over 40 000 permutations
and a deck of 52 cards that's 52
factorial permutations which is 8 times
10 to the 67th power
which is all this that means there are
more ways to shuffle an ordinary deck of
52 cards
than there are atoms on the earth
putting it another way
if you shuffled an ordinary deck of
cards once every second which i can't do
but if you did
in order to shuffle your way into every
possible combination of cards you would
be shuffling for over november decilion
years
don't know what a november decillion is
i didn't either i had to look it up
turns out it's a trillion times a
trillion times a trillion
times a trillion times a trillion times
a trillion years
that hurts a little doesn't it that
brings us to our final topic
big numbers there's a number so large
that if you try to imagine it
your consciousness would collapse in on
itself forming a mental black hole
oh great what could possibly go wrong
[Music]
our brands do not like big numbers even
if our bank accounts do
we do okay conceptualizing hundreds and
thousands and millions but when we start
thinking of numbers bigger than that
we get we get stressed at some point
numbers stop
meaning anything they just become these
theoretical imaginary
stuffs in 1940 mathematician edward
kasner wrote a book called
mathematics and the imagination now in
that book he coined a term
for one followed by a hundred zeros or
ten to the power of a hundred he called
it a google which is just a word that
his nephew made up
khasner being the show-off that he is
then proposed an even
bigger number called a googleplex which
is 10 to the power of google or one
followed by
a google zeros well kasner himself
called this number unfathomable
did i say it right
[Laughter]
a googleplex is a number so large that
if you wrote it out in an actual
notebook
your notebook would weigh more than the
entire earth all the earth
fun fact the original google search
engine was based on sites backlinking to
each other so they called the algorithm
backrub that name was clearly awful so
they decided to change it to google
because they wanted to index an
unfathomable unfathomable a
lot of web pages you know the only
reason google is spelled the way it is
is because larry page misspelled it when
he registered the domain name
so the name of one of the biggest
companies in history is actually a typo
they seem to be doing okay with it
numbers get even bigger than a
googleplex much bigger in 1971
mathematician ronald graham established
a number
as the solution to a mathematical riddle
link
link link graham's number as it came to
be known
is so mind-boggling the human brain
can't even picture it
there's 64 steps required to obtain
graham's number and after the first few
steps
the sequence contains 7.6 trillion
threes
i don't know what happens after those
few steps but it sounds
sounds awful according to the website
physics astronomy
if you even try to imagine graham's
number your head would break down
into a mental black hole because it
cannot store the information required to
envisage it
i think that means c and if you think
that sounds like an exaggeration
so did i but john baez who's a
mathematical physicist at ucla
he said the mental hole description is a
ridiculous
underestimation of how big graham's
number really is
now i'd love to show you graham's number
i really would but
there actually isn't enough space in the
entire universe to write down all the
digits so
i'll just stick to making history by
shuffling my playing cards
and remember every time you shuffle your
own deck of playing cards
you probably just made history too and
now
you know why
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today my name is aj
that's hecklefish this has been the
y-files what other crazy math facts are
out there let me know in the comments
section
and if you enjoyed this video hit the
like button it really helps us out
if you haven't subscribed please
consider subscribing if we didn't earn
your subscription today
i promise we'll keep making nerdy fun
content until we do earn it
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you
are appreciated
uh is anybody seeing this hello